تحت هدير الضربات الصاروخية
وانفجارات المدفعية ، ظهر دليل على وجود
تهديد مميت آخر يسمى
الذخائر المتسكعة أو طائرات كاميكازي بدون طيار
التي جلبها الروس لتضرب بقوة
خلف الخطوط الأوكرانية ، فإن الجانب
الإرهابي لهذه الأسلحة
هو عامل نفسي مهم
في ساحة المعركة
على عكس الهائل.  الطائرات العسكرية بدون طيار التي تطير
مئات الأميال في الساعة عبر مسافات شاسعة في
كثير من الأحيان لإسقاط الصواريخ
والعودة إلى الوطن طائرات بدون طيار بدون
طيار صغيرة بطيئة ويمكن التخلص منها ،
على سبيل المثال ، تزن Switchblade 300 أقل
من ستة أرطال ويمكن حملها في
حقيبة ظهر بسرعة وسهولة.
رحلة بحرية في حوالي 60 ميلاً في الساعة
لمدة 15 دقيقة أثناء
البحث عن أصول العدو القريبة والكاميرات الموجودة على متن
الطائرة بمجرد تحديد الهدف
وإعطاء الأمر للطائرة بدون طيار يمكن أن تندفع بسرعة تصل إلى 100
ميل في الساعة وتنفجر عند الارتطام
ولكن كما حدث في المعركة
يقول محللون عسكريون محتدمون إن الأوكرانيين الذين يمتلكون
مثل هذه الطائرات بدون طيار قد قلبوا الطاولة
على الروس  Ng لهم تأثير أكثر فتكًا بكثير ،
أعتقد أن تخميني الشخصي هو أنه
ربما يكون حوالي 20 إلى 30 في المائة من عمليات
القتل التي يسجلها الأوكرانيون
ضد الدروع الروسية وضدك
تعرف
الكيانات الروسية الأخرى
ربما يرجع ذلك إلى
توظيفهم الناجح جدًا لهذه الطائرات بدون طيار
وفقًا للمحللين  تتناسب طائرات كاميكازي بدون طيار
تمامًا مع الفرق الصغيرة
سريعة الحركة التي يفضلها
الأوكرانيون ، حيث يصعب
اكتشاف الأسلحة ويمكنها اختراق المواقع على بعد أميال
، ويبدو أن العديد من الأنظمة ذات الأحجام والإمكانيات المتفاوتة قيد الاستخدام
والولايات المتحدة ملتزمة
بتعزيز الأوكرانية  جهد مع مئات من
تلك الأنظمة التي تعمل بالشفرات مما
يدل على التزامنا بإرسال
أحدث أنظمتنا إلى أوكرانيا
للدفاع عنها